ENEMY.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BIG BREAKING NEWS ON MULTIPLE
FRONTS.
A FORMER TOP PROSECUTOR FROM
UKRAINE HAS NOW IMPLICATED,
SLEEPY, CREEPY, CRAZY UNCLE JOE
AND WHAT IS A VERY SERIOUS
CRIME.
WE HAVE BRAND-NEW EVIDENCE
INCLUDING A SIGNED UNDER THE
THREAT OF PERJURY, THE REAL
THREAT OF PERJURY THAT HE LIED.
RUDY GIULIANI'S TIMELINE COMING
UP TONIGHT AND IT'S VERY
REVEALING, ALSO THIS IMPORTANT
NEWS AND INFORMATION WILL PROVE
THAT THE MEDIA MOB HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE COVERING FOR
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON.
ALSO THE FRAUDULENT NANCY PELOSI
SHIFT, IMPEACHMENT CIRCUS IS
GETTING OFF TO A HORRIFIC START.
THEIR FIRST WITNESS JUST
LITERALLY SHOT DOWN AND DEFLATED
ALL OF THE LEFTS ANTI-TRUMP
IMPEACHMENT FANTASIES AND BY THE
WAY, THE COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF
HAS BEEN CAUGHT IN YET ANOTHER
DISGUSTING LIE.
THERE ARE GROWING CALLS FOR THE
LIAR IN CHIEF, THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF TO BE KICKED OFF HIS
COMMITTEE.
BUCKLE UP, THERE WILL BE A
BRAND-NEW DEEP STATE LEAK.
THIS IS A WARNING, PRETTY MUCH
MINUTE-BY-MINUTE SPIRIT A NEW
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER,
WHISTLE-BLOWER EVERY SECOND.
WE HAVE TRACTION HERE!
CHINA, CNN!
MUCH AGO FAKE CNN REPORTING
ANOTHER LEAK WITH ANOTHER PHONE
CALL BY ANOTHER WORLD LEADER,
THIS TIME THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA.
THE CROP MEDIA IS NOT TRYING TO
FLOOD THE ZONE WITH ANTI-TRUMP
SPECULATION, ESPECIALLY SINCE
UKRAINE IS BLOWING UP IN THEIR
FACES AND BACKFIRING.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS TO
CHINA.
HE WILL SAY THIS TO RUSH ON THIS
TO THE SAUDIS.
THEY WILL NOT DEMAND EVERY
TRANSCRIPT EVER OF EVERY
CONVERSATION OUR PRESIDENT HAS
HAS COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S PLAY THIS GAME.
I WOULD LIKE TO RELEASE -- THE
RELEASE OF EVERY PHONE CALL
TRANSCRIPT, BY THE WAY I WOULD
LIKE EVERY OBAMA HE RAN, MUELLER
TRANSCRIPT.
I WOULD LIKE THE OBAMA POLLUTANT
TRANSCRIPTS.
WHAT IS THE FLEXIBILITY
THEY SHOWED AFTER HIS
REELECTION?
YOU GOT THE POINT, IT'S ONLY
FISHING EXPEDITION.
FIRST WE HAVE THE HEALTH CARE,
AND PEACH DONALD TRUMP AND THEN
MANUFACTURE A REASON LATER.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS IN A
MOMENT, BUT FIRST WE START WITH
THE RAMPANT DISHONESTY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR CLOSE
FRIENDS, ALLIES TIED AT THE HIP
COMEDY MEDIA MOB.
TONIGHT IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE
INVASION OF THE BODY SNATCHERS,
MEMBER THAT MOVIE?
THEY LOOK LIKE US BUT THEY DON'T
THINK LIKE ANYTHING WE
RECOGNIZE.
DEVOID OF ANY REAL PERCEPTION.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THE LEFT
KNOWS OR CAN SEE THEIR OWN
HYPOCRISY THAT IS GLARING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
UNADULTERATED, SEWER, SWAMP
POLITICS THAT DRIVES THEM OR A
QUEST TO REGAIN POWER, THAT'S A
PART EVENT OR THEIR BLIND
PSYCHOTIC RAGE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT LIBERALS
ARE CONSTANTLY -- WE KNOW THEY
LOOK DOWN ON THE CONSERVATIVES,
THE PEOPLE AND WE SEE WHEN THEY
CALL US SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE.
GUILTY, DEPLORABLE, THAT LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
AS OBAMA ONCE SAID, THOSE ANGRY
AMERICANS THAT CLING TO THEIR
GOD.
CLEAN GUNS, SECOND AMENDMENT
BIBLES ON RELIGION.
WE ALL NEED GOD IN OUR LIVES.
THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR REVEALING
THOSE CONSERVATIVES THAT ARE PRO
LIFE AND PRO-SECOND AMENDMENT --
THEY'RE NOT NEW YORKERS.
HE SAID THAT.
NOBODY NEEDS TEN BULLETS TO KILL
A DEER.
HE DOESN'T LEAVE ME SECOND
AMENDMENT EITHER AND HAS
EMBARRASSING FIVE-MINUTE
AUDITION OF BEING A RADIO HOST,
REMEMBER, AND EMOTIONAL ALEC
BALDWIN.ANGRY THAT ME AND
MARK LEVIN TAG TEAMED HIM AND HE
CALLED ME A IGNORANT FORMER
CONSTRUCTION WORK HACK FROM
LONG ISLAND.
GUILTY OF THAT, I'M VERY PROUD
OF MY TWO DECADES LONG
BLUE-COLLAR HARDWORKING HISTORY.
MY MOM WAS A PRISON GUARD WHO
WORKED 16 HOUR SHIFTS FOR 25
YEARS.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE SO MUCH
DISDAIN FOR HONEST HARDWORKING
AMERICANS WITH A DIFFERENT
CLINICAL OPINION.
OKAY, I LIKE TO SHOP AT WALMART,
COSTCO, TARGET, YOU NAME IT.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AND THEN WE
PAY THESE LEAPS AND SALARIES AND
PAY FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE PLANS.
THEY'RE BETTER THAN THE
OBAMACARE EXCHANGES WE ARE STUCK
WITH A LONG SHOT.
THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE NOW LOST
ALL PERSPECTIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET'S LOOK AT
CREEPY UNCLE JOE'S UKRAINIAN
SCANDAL.
LET'S PLAY A GAME.
LET'S REPLACE THE NAME VP
JOE BIDEN AND WE WILL SAY VP
DONALD TRUMP.
I KNOW HE WON'T LET THE
REDUCTION AND TITLE, BUT PLAY
ALONG AND REPLACING THEM WITH
HUNTER BIDEN AND WE WILL CALL
HIM DON JR.
WHAT YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN?
WHAT IF DON JR. WERE TAKING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM WHAT IS
A SHADY UKRAINIAN OIL GIANT,
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM CHINA
WHILE HIS FATHER WAS
VICE PRESIDENT?
LET'S SAY IT'S DON JR. WHO HAD
ZERO EXPERIENCE WITH EITHER
COUNTRY OR ANY OF THE
BUSINESSES, ENERGY, OIL, GAS,
PRIVATE EQUITY THAT WERE PAYING
THESE HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY!
WHAT IF VICE PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP LEVERAGED A BILLION
U.S. TAX DOLLARS TO GET A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED WHO
WAS INVESTIGATING DONALD JR.'S
COMPANY.
WHAT YOU THINK THE MEDIA MOB
WOULD BE CALLING THIS?
TO THINK THEY WOULD SAY
CONSPIRACY THEORY OR A HOAX?
THE ENDLESS, BREATHLESS
HYSTERICAL REPORTING FOR WEEKS
ON END.
WHAT A POLITICAL REPORTED THAT
AN RNC OPERATIVE AND CONTRACTOR
WAS WORKING HAND-IN-HAND WITH
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT DIGGING UP
DIRT ON HILLARY CLINTON FOR THE
2016 ELECTION AND THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL.
WHAT IF THAT SAME ARTICLE READ
THAT UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO
SABOTAGE HOW THE RATE WHAT     .
WHAT WOULD THE MEDIA MOB
REACTION BE?
WHAT ABOUT THE LETTER WITH THE
BRAZEN EFFORTS BY THE DNC TO USE
THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE FOR
THE EXPRESS PURPOSE OF FINDING
NEGATIVE INFORMATION ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
WHAT IF THE LETTER WAS ABOUT THE
RNC AND HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
WHAT IF IT WAS DONALD TRUMP WHO
FUNNELED MONEY THROUGH A LAW
FIRM CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION
TO THEN HIRE A RESEARCH GROUP,
FUSION GPS TO HIRE A X BORN SPY
TO DIG UP RUSSIAN DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON, PROBABLY COME
ANNOYINGLY FROM THE BEGINNING
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION?
COME TO THINK OF IT,
DONALD TRUMP HAD A SERVER,
PRIVATE SERVER, TOP-SECRET
MATERIAL ON IT AND WHAT HAVE
DONALD TRUMP DELETED 33,000
EMAILS THAT WERE SUBPOENAED AND
THEN DESTROYED HIS CELL PHONES?
THEN HE BLEACH THE HARD DRIVE?
WITH THE MEDIA MOB CARE?
I SALE OF THIS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
FUNNY BECAUSE THIS IS HOW SICK,
IT'S CANCEROUS WHAT THIS MOB IN
THE MEDIA IS DOING TO THIS
COUNTRY EVERY DAY.
THIS ALSO APPLIES TO THE CURRENT
UKRAINIAN WITCH HUNT AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND AS YOU KNOW
DEMOCRATS IN THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA ARE GIVING HIM THE WHITE
GLOVE TREATMENT WITH THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO IS NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER!
IT'S NOT A FIRSTHAND
INFORMATION, AS HEARSAY.
IF THE GUY RUNNING IT, THE
COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS
OFFICE, EVEN GIVING THIS FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ADVICE ON HOW TO
PREPARE THE CRITICAL COMPLAINT
AND GIVEN THE ADVICE TO GET A
LAWYER.
THE MEDIA MOB'S PRAISED THIS
PERSON OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THANK GOODNESS WE HAVE
VIDEOTAPE.
I WAS ACTUALLY ON THE AIR DURING
THE CLINTON IMPEACHMENT.
I KNOW, I'VE NOW STARTED MY 24TH
YEAR AT FOX -- A LONG TIME.
IN THE 90s WHEN LINDA TRIPP --
SHE WAS A WHISTLE-BLOWER AGAINST
CLINTON.
THE MEDIA MOB TRADED THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER A LOT DIFFERENTLY
AND I THINK IT'S WORTH TAKING A
TRIP DOWN MEMORY LANE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FRIENDSHIP MEANS DIFFERENT
THINGS TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE, BUT
FEW PEOPLE EXPECT TO HAVE THEIR
FRIENDSHIPS BETRAYED WITH HAVING
THEIR PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS
TAPED.
>> I CAN IMAGINE THAT THEY WOULD
GO SCHEMING THE WAY SHE DID AND
ABSOLUTELY DEFINED AND VIOLATING
MONICA WHEN SHE DID.
>> COWORKERS VIEWED HER AS A
BUSYBODY, SHE ALWAYS BEEN A
SNOOP AND A GOSSIP?
>> SHE IS SOMEBODY WHO HAS HAD A
PATTERN OF INTEREST AND OTHER
PEOPLE'S MARITAL LIVES.
>> THE STORY OF LINDA TRIPP'S
BETRAYAL IS VERY UNAPPEALING AND
SHE COMES OFF AS A CONNIVING AND
REALLY NOT A LIKABLE PERSON.
>> Sean: CONNIVING, NOT
LIKABLE PERSON, IMAGINE THE
MEDIA MOB TRADE IN THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER LIKE THAT, BUT
ALSO BREAKING -- IS
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
WHO FOLLOWED A COMPLAINT ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PHONE CALL
WITH UKRAINE, REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT, LIKE THE LAWYER SHE
HIRED TO.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HE OR SHE HAVE
NO DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE PHONE
CALL, ZERO, NOTHING IN THE
COMPLAINT WAS ENTIRELY BASED ON
HEARSAY WHICH WOULD NOT BE
ADMISSIBLE IN THE COURT OF LAW.
MEDIA REPORTS.
THE OFFICE OF THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF, THEY SPOKE DIRECTLY TO
THIS PERSON AND ENCOURAGE THEM
TO GET A LAWYER AND FIRED A
REPORT, BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP THE
COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF FOR GOING
ON MS BNC, THAT WOULD BE AREA 5,
RACHEL MADDOW'S CONSPIRACY
CHANNEL AND THE DNC NETWORK
THERE THIS SEPTEMBER, LYING
THROUGH HIS TEETH HE SAID "WE
HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY WITH
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER."
HARDLY THE FIRST TIME HE HAS
BEEN CAUGHT IN A LIVE, THE
BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS.
HE ONCE HAD YET DIRECT EVIDENCE,
DIRECT EVIDENCE OF THE TRUMPET
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THE EVIDENCE WAS IN PLAIN SIGHT.
WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR IT.
COME ON THE PROGRAM AND BRING IT
WITH YOU.
MORE RECENTLY AND A COMMITTEE
HEARING, HE PERFORMED A DRAMATIC
READING, HE DIDN'T GET WHAT HE
WANTED IN THE TRANSCRIPT OF THE
PHONE CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT.
ANYWAY, FROM THAT TRANSCRIPT HE
HAD TO COMPLETELY FABRICATE AT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T WHAT HE WANTED
IT TO BE SO WE MADE IT UP AND
CALLED IT A PARODY.
SOMEONE MIGHT WANT TO TELL
SPEAKER PELOSI THAT HER
PARTNER IN CRIME AS A SERIAL
LIAR.
SHE SEEMS TOTALLY UNAWARE OF HIS
LIES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KNOW YOU SUPPORT HIM, BUT
WAS IT RIGHT FOR HIM TO HAVE
THAT DRAMATIC INTERPRETATION OF
THE PRESIDENTS PHONE CALL LAST
WEEK?
>> I WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TURNED OUT WITHOUT A PHONE CALL
WAS ABOUT.
I WANT THEM TO HEAR IT.
IT IS FAIR, IT'S SAD, BUT IT'S
USING THE PRESIDENT'S OWN WORDS.
>> THOSE WEALTHY PRESIDENTS
WORDS BUT THERE WAS AN
INTERPRETATION.
>> HE DID NOT MAKE IT UP.
>> Sean: WHIPS A DAISY.
1 OF HER BRILLIANT STAFFERS I
WANT TO GET ON A COMPUTER SO SHE
CAN SEE WHAT SCHIFF IS UP TO.
BY THE WAY YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TELL HER A MILE FROM HER HOUSE,
THERE IS A BIG PROBLEM WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AND IN THE STREETS.
NOT IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD, BUT 1
MILE AWAY.
SHE ALSO NEEDS TO ANSWER TO SOME
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
FRAUDULENT IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
A LETTER TO THE SPEAKER,
McCARTHY IS DEMANDING
RIGHTFULLY SO ANSWERS TO THE
FOLLOWING PROCEDURES REQUIRED
AND ANY OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS.
"DO YOU INTEND TO GRANT POWER TO
BOTH EACH YEAR AND THE RANKING
MEMBER AT THE COMMITTEE LEVEL?
DO YOU INTEND TO REQUIRE THAT
ALL SUBPOENAS BE SUBJECTED TO A
VOTE OF THE FULL COMMITTEE TO
THE REQUEST OF EITHER THE CHAIR
OF THE RANKING MEMBER?
DO YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
ATTEND ALL HEARINGS AND
DEPOSITIONS?
DO YOU INTEND TO HAVE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
PRESENT EVIDENCE?
THE PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL THE
RIGHT TO OBJECT TO THE
ADMITTANCE OF EVIDENCE?
YOU INTEND TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDENTS COUNCIL THE RIGHT TO
RECOMMEND A WITNESS LIST?
DO YOU INTEND TO REFER ALL
FINDINGS ON IMPEACHMENT TO
CHAIRMAN NADLER ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AS PRESCRIBED IN RULE
TEN OF THE RULES OF THE HOUSE?"
IS HE IN CHARGE OF LEADING THIS
INQUIRY AS HAD BEEN REPORTED?
THE QUESTIONS ARE STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURES FOR ANY
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING, ANYTHING
LESS IS A SHAM.
BY THE WAY, THREE TIMES WE'VE
HAD IMPEACHMENT, THE HOUSE WOULD
USUALLY VOTE ON THE INQUIRY.
SHE DOES NOT LIE NOT TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE IF THEY DO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS -- KEVIN McCARTHY IS
ASKING FOR WOULD FOLLOW.
TOMORROW THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
SEND A SIMILAR LETTER DARING
PELOSI TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT HER
WHICH I WANT TO.
LET'S PUT THEM ALL THE RECORD.
I SAY CALL THE ROLL.
TIME THE SPEAKER, SHE SERIOUS OR
IS THIS A BIG POLITICAL STUNT
THAT'S OUT TO HURT THE COUNTRY
AND DIVIDE THE COUNTRY FURTHER?
WHATEVER HER TRUE INTENTIONS,
HER IMPEACHMENT CHARADE IS
GETTING OFF TO A HORRIFIC START.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
BREAKING TONIGHT AND WE WILL
HAVE FIRST-HAND INFORMATION
COMING UP, THE VERY FIRST STAR
WITNESS IN THE PROCEEDING.
THE U.S. SPECIAL ENVOY TO
UKRAINE, KURT BULGER
REPORTEDLY -- I HAVE HEARD FROM
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM, DEVASTATED
AND DESTROYED THE DEMOCRATS
UKRAINIAN CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
ALL OF THEM!
BY THE WAY, CONGRATULATIONS.
I HEAR A BIG DAY IS COMING UP.
THIS COMES ON THE HEELS OF
ANOTHER MAJOR DISAPPOINTMENT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THIS WEEK AT THE FAR LEFT
MEMBERS WERE ABSOLUTELY GIDDY
WITH ANTICIPATION OVER AN URGENT
STATE DEPARTMENT BRIEFING ABOUT
UKRAINE.
IT TURNED OUT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT'S NONPARTISAN
INSPECTOR GENERAL PRESENTED THEM
WITH EVIDENCE OF DNC COLLUSION
WITH UKRAINE AND A TIMELINE OF
HIS SHAKEDOWN WITH UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR.
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA MOB, IS
THE EVIDENCE A DISPROVEN
CONSPIRACY THEORY?
IT'S BLOWING UP IN YOUR FACE AND
YOU ARE HELPING DONALD TRUMP IN
THE PROCESS.
WE HAVE A WAS DEVASTATING
TIMELINE, THIS PUT TOGETHER BY
THE FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
RUDY GIULIANI WAS ON LAST NIGHT.
THIS PAINTS A MUCH DIFFERENT
PICTURE.
KEEP IN MIND THIS TIME FRAME, HE
BEGAN HIS INVESTIGATION INTO
BIDEN AND UKRAINE WELL BEFORE
BIDEN EVER ANNOUNCES HIS
INTENTION TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2018.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
WAS CONDUCTING RESEARCH BECAUSE
HE WAS STILL DEFENDING HIS
CLIENT TO THE FROM THE LINE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
ROBERT MUELLER AND HAS
WITCH HUNT.
FOR ALL OF THE WILL FLURRY
IGNORANT MEMBERS OF THE MOB WERE
SHIELDING JOE BIDEN TONIGHT, YOU
MAY WANT TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THIS TIMELINE.
I WILL TRY TO READ IT SLOWLY TO
YOU.
IT STARTS IN 2010.
THE OLIGARCH IN THE PRO-RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT OF VICTOR JANKOVIC
SHE STARTED GRANTING HIS COMPANY
VALUABLE GAS EXPLORATION, THAT
IS CALLED PARIS' HOLDINGS,
LET'S FLASH FORWARD,
PRESIDENT OBAMA NAMED
VICE PRESIDENT SLEEPY, CREEPY
UNCLE JOE IS THE POINT MAN FOR
UKRAINE.
IN THE SAME MONTH THE PRESIDENT
IS OUSTED AND HE AND THE
OLIGARCH BEHIND THE ISSUE, THEY
FLEE TO RUSSIA.
IN APRIL OF 2014, HE PLACES
HUNTER BIDEN AND EVAN ARCHER
WITH HIS PARTNER AND THE FORMER
AIDE TO THEN JOHN KERRY ON THE
BOARD.
EITHER PERSON HAD NEITHER
EXPERIENCE THAT WE CAN FIND IN
OIL, GAS OR ENERGY.
NONE OF THEM HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE
ON UKRAINE.
THEY WERE PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THEIR EXPERTISE AND
WHAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
EXPERTISE AT KNOWING JOE BIDEN I
GUESS.
AN AUGUST 2014 UKRAINE'S
PROSECUTOR, HE OPENED A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE REESE MY
HOLDINGS, THAT'S A
FACT.
THEY IDENTIFIED AS PERSONS OF
INTEREST IN THE INVESTIGATION.
BY THE WAY, PEOPLE UNDER
INVESTIGATION ARE NOTIFIED AND
JANUARY OF 2015, HE IS NAMED A
FUGITIVE BY UKRAINE'S GOVERNMENT
UNDER BIDEN ON BOARD, AND MAY OF
2015 HUNTER BIDEN MEETS WITH THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STATE TONY
BLANK AND REGARDING CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HOLDINGS.
IN AUGUST HILLARY CLINTON
ALLEGEDLY TELLS VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN SHE WILL NOT GO AFTER
HUNTER BIDEN IF HE RUNS.
IN DECEMBER OF 2015 VP JOE BIDEN
TELLS THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE
THAT HE MUST DISMISS THE
PROSECUTOR GENERAL VICTOR SHOW
AGAIN.
AFTER "THE NEW YORK TIMES" GAVE
HIM A HEADS UP.
IN FEBRUARY 2016, VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
TALKING ON THE PHONE ABOUT
REMOVING THE PROSECUTOR GENERAL.
CAN WE PLEASE RELEASE THIS
TRANSCRIPT?
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND THEN
MARCH OF 2016, BIDEN AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT ISSUES HAS WOOD
PRO QUOTE, THE SHAKEDOWN THAT HE
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR T
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR X
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR D
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR L
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR A
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR S
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR U
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR L
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR H
WOULD UPHOLD 8 BILLION OF YEAR T
PROSECUTOR GENERAL IS FIRED.
A FEW DAYS LATER HE WAS FIRED
AND BIDEN BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
AND MAY 80 PROSECUTOR GENERAL IS
HIRED AND THAT SAME SPRING THE
NEW PROSECUTOR MEETS WITH
THE AMERICAN AMBASSADOR.
SHE ALLEGEDLY TELLS HIM TO DROP
SEVERAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
MEANWHILE AND YOU AND UKRAINIAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY ANNOUNCES
IT'S UNCOVERED A MASSIVE FRAUD
SCHEME INVOLVING -- THAT'S
RIGHT, HUNTER BIDEN'S PARTNER.
THAT SAME MONTH BIDEN MEETS WITH
UKRAINIAN PRIME MINISTER AND A
FEW MONTHS LATER IN NOVEMBER
UKRAINE ANNOUNCED THE CASE
SURROUNDING THEY CLOSED JUST
LIKE THAT.
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA MOB SAY
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE, IT'S A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
REALLY?
NO EVIDENCE?
WHY WAS HUNTER BIDEN ON THE
BOARD?
WHAT WAS HIS QUALIFICATIONS?
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T HIS
EXPERTISE AND THE ENERGY SECTOR
OR THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE AND
CLEARLY KNOWS ABOUT HIS SON'S
LUCRATIVE BUSINESS DEALS.
BY THE WAY, HERE HE IS PICTURED
ON A GOLF COURSE -- THAT'S IN
THE SUMMER OF 2014.
THE FELLOW MEMBER DEVON ARCHER.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, HE HAD A MORE
LUCRATIVE DEAL WITH THE BANK OF
CHINA GRADE FROM RUSSIA,
UKRAINE, THE LEFT HAS BEEN
SMEARING PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
ONE LIGHT, ONE PIECE OF
PARCHMENT, ONE CONSPIRACY
THEORY, ONE WORKS, COAX AFTER
ANOTHER BUT TONIGHT THEY'RE
SCHEMING WILL BLOW UP AGAIN
JUST LIKE RUSSIA IN THEIR
FACE.
BY THE WAY, CREEPY, SLEEPY, JOE,